[Applause] Penguins going overtime for the second
time of their last three games here's Crosby
right in splits the defense Crosby tries to WRA it
around gel there he curls it wide gets it back and
puts it over the net it's taken away by the pen
what a play by leang here comes gel he's got two
on the game for the hatrick across L to save Ur
is Pittsburgh with a couple of good opportunities
Letang moving away from sanine who's right with
him gives it to Smith his drop pass taken away
here come the Flyers it's Scott lton dangles
around Smith but Riley Smith a good recovery and
he's going to atone for his mistake here he comes
three men here Smith with ell it's Smith shot save
made by Ur in his career in shootouts a chance
to give the pens The Edge get so up over the
net hoping you can hold him over on that right
side of the net net coming back across trying
to Shan cier 11 for 40 in his career in shootouts
opens up and scores one nothing fire I love this
move I mean backhand forehand changes about 5T
off the post and in chance to tie things up here
in the shootout the captain stopped by uren Ryan
Russ five for six and shootout of D in his career
has to score Cuts in beaks Arison the save and
the Flyers win it Sam Arison now seven of seven
in shootouts he stopped every shot fired his
way he's mobbed an extremely valuable second
Point pass neck able to swoop in going to the
net there's wo with a stop and was in a pretty
good spot ruins take over aead it goes to Maran
KNE Landers back M treding to get back Maran sto
by wall by olark elander finds Riley Riley in
front and swept off his stick elander tried to
play that back to the point nobody was there H FR
for marer kicked Away by Omar now lead de it's a
breckle p zaka stop rebound from with two stops a
loose puck in front and now Morgan Riley up ahead
KN Lander behind everybody for the win over with
the stop great chances either way and that puck
alive for poster duck back in drops gets it back
Po and wall going to hold on terrific action here
three on three oh man you got to love three on
three for the Maple Leafs as the brush gather
speed heads in in behind the net to back up top
grizzli shooting oh sit on that once you gain the
zone and do a little Around the World opening up
he's trying to get this to hit off of H oh what a
job there by Bel Captain Captain versus captain
and it's Boston again getting first possession
mck with stick more to the D trying to jam that
home back in the leavs head to the attack back
over the line final minute of overtime m to the
net oh BS what a stop on a brilliant play is it
still loose for M Mar a little cross and go Mar
pulls it back around the Stick of Charlie M boy
and now KNE Lander deliberately through Center
look out blows a tire breakway David pass KN
for the win well again rebounded FR scores the
Boston ruins in overtime red Maran has is the
winner tonight we get another look at it here
try to go five [Applause] hole what an effort
by Boston that's a great win the compete level
there the details were good defensively this
could be a high powered offense they're about to
look to change here goes Larkin with some room
and a shot and a save rebound R around right up
from once it came back it comes for Walman just
held in at the line for lin looks for wman again
with Slap Shot Jake wman the gritty the Red Wings
wi it 5 to [Applause] four 54 seconds in what a
shot what a relief on a great release and Dylan
Lin will get an assist he's had a a greaty night
Ducks lose possession again Ronson and drops it
off glub save Gibson who wants to play the Pucket
got a good read on you could see he wanted to give
it up in a hurry we played almost 3 minutes of
overtime no kale mot Here Comes McKinnon with
speed backhander another glove saved by Gibson
who shoves it away and he is having words with the
referee who was in the corner actually overtime
cuts to the slot drops it off Off the Bench room
for color color forced wide as it was knocked off
his stick but he recovers possession 20 seconds
left in overtime he hits the brakes on the wall
takes a look now walks it towards the goal TR
oh what off Escape crov made a huge P save former
Quebec League Player of the Year in on Gibson who
gets a piece mckinon works it in through the top
of the circle McKinnon looks shoots at a save by
Gibson first time we see Leo Carlson in a shootout
he hit a post in overtime he has a goal and an
assist and he'll sweep in off the right side the
big left hand shot shot almost fumbled it oh then
just skapes it around PR theop has got some quick
hands this Puck rolls on him too but he doesn't
panic gets it under control and then one move like
that and prosop is swimming Gibson can win it with
a save here against Ronin but what a move here
comes Ronin Gibson out to cut the angle and he
gets a glove on it and the ducks come all the way
back and end the losing streak well done to stay
on side the shot missed the target turnover cier
holds to Connected the shot and elovich with the
save goes malan again you're going to clear this
up it goes off a stick it's a race for the puck
out comes the goalie in comes lman it's played
ahead here's Carlson on the right side to Malin
Malin back to Carlson to blast the Save By Heart
L will play it ahead he's got sanheim and sanheim
couldn't get it now he's got it with a game on his
stick sanheim off the post lton picks up the butt
lton from the angle his shot that's denied at the
side by the 12 remaining in the overtime and it's
Crosby Crosby to the Philadelphia line drops to
gensel gensel moves in the shot save Carter hard
and no rebound to be had and the Flyers win the
draw sanheim spins it ahead and here's connect
moving up with Cur two on one connecting with a
puck connecting holes two he scores he now has
his second overtime game winner of the Year fires
win it as they knocked off the Penguins two to
one andit into the offensive end he'll pull up
and flip it out High Thomas trying to settle a
bouncing Puck down low Thomas off to musis scor
pav nit was all alone down low and the blows Win
It 38 seconds into overtime Kopitar moving in deep
hands it off for kempe kempe in turn for dowy and
to Kopitar to dowy a one timer he [Applause]
scores 10 straight road wins for the Kings
Drew dowy unloads from the top of the left Circle
pull up for barel forat now on the nice one timer
off the bar fck it nice saving off the off the
post there on a Islanders around the perimeter
here lot of Zone time barzel got free with a shot
and cocking and comes up with the save Puck was
available eckan got to it first he sends it ahead
now the Sharks hurrying up ice Eckland two-on one
with Ferraro William eckan S soken Puck available
Nelson slips by grin it's Dolson he's rushing
ahead Noah doson cutting in left it behind and
it wouldn't roll into the Shark Zone for Noah
doson he'll send it back for barzel doson loads up
shoots hits the post oh my that's two goal posts
here on the third for the hitor now Eckland off
his foot but it ends up on the stick of granin
got to go he'll come to center 8 seconds to go
Brin in E shoots and scor William Eckland wins
it in overtime what a comeback by the [Applause]
Sharks use the defenseman for the Islanders as a
screen the Islanders are tired they can't get
off granin pushes the pace right here watch
this little tow drag boom nice little flash screen
too Bard steps on it Bard over the line Bard saves
Soros and he swatched the puck out to the circle
final minute of three on three Nashville has the
puck Roman Yosi the Lefty Yosi save solder Bloom
long rebound Bard Bard and O'Reilly Bard cuts to
the middle he shoots save Soros he got a piece a
lot of tired skaters now yeah you never see Conor
Bard out of breath but this time the chances
he's generating iist takes the puck and away
we go in this shootout in Chicago way wide iqu
he scores here's Conor Bard's NHL shootout debut
on yussi Soros Bard scores oh it's Beauty the
crowd has started to get to their feet O'Reilly
in round two he goes to the opposite side brings
it to the middle he scores a beautiful backhand
top shelf watch him come his body's going to go
across he's going to bring the backand back and
he just lifts it now Tyler Johnson a bid to tie
the shootout at two save Soros he kicks it away
he's getting booed here comes forsberg he scores
the Predators go three for three in the shootout
and they get the two points at the United Center
ran looking for wman who opens up to take the pass
Raymond off his back foot and now a foot rais
and here's zland in alone on the Breakaway grin
scores they did it again the sharks with an
unbelievable comeback and then the overtime
winner the Red Wings throw the puck back this
is going to be a good stick check right there
and then little bit of a hold to the stick
there was going to be a penalty lurking on
that situation but then johnon with speed around
oetkin behind the net about to wrap around it's
dead to Ben drops it right back to Johnston
Johnston dangling shoot save made by lingren
tough wrist shot into the corner back to the
point Carlson across ofin again tries one save
made by Wedgewood and the oh he's the slowest
shootout performer in the league here Wedgewood
Waits who Nets off moves in misses goes in and
Meandering is generous and he ends up missing
the Nets Jon Robertson one for two and shootout
opportunities this season he'll try first for
Dallas for the forehand scar strome had two goals
in regulation time on the shootout now denied by
Wedgewood the great eight to try and keep the game
alive for Washington to the backand den not Again
by Wedgewood and the shootout Victory goes to
the Dallas Stars off the boards in the Buffalo
Zone ahead to Middle St he gets to Center across
the Montreal line slides it across to Thompson
comes to the middle Thompson shakes and bakes in
the shot by middle stack kyoso needs to protect
the puck high in the zone here till Dalene gets
back and there he is Dalene creates the Lan and
fires the shot stop by Primo stick in his right
hand now makes his way to the far Circle between
the circles Thompson stuck by Primo Suzuki wide
to the left followed by Levi Suzuki Dees Levi
pek save and a beauty olon to the right Circle
works his way in scor Victor gon in the shootout
Coffield again to the same left Circle against
Levi Coffield between between the wickets open
them up enough and it's one a piece Here Comes
power to the right Circle slowly power creeping
towards the net looking scores but right now
it's Arizona native against Ste Levi to the
right Circle and with speed Yona Shake scores 22
in the shootout but turkus coming into the same
Circle right side not a lot of speed trying to
open him up and that time M Creo says that seen
it in his career and he's got a chance to win
it slowski built speed to the SL SC what a move
your lovsky What a Night by the 19-year-old
what a move right here patience just to get
around the outstretched Levi's left leg right
here stops he brings it back and Levi already
in what is their 26th game of the year what is
the king's Shootout record 0 and2 which surprises
me a little bit Kemp shot deflected by doson
chipped on by Holstrom Paso a chance to win it
scores no history tonight on Long Island JG
Pou completes the comeback H but guest came
out hard watch him come out hard and they just
not able to cover up the fiveable you got to
drop that stick down I'm guessing that's what
he tried to do going back for kov he's being
tracked by Jordan Everly he'll tab it back to
Brandon Hegel now Hegel will wind it up Hegel
up the right side trying to skate away from Everly
Brandon Hegel across they score n could jop it's a
lightning strike it's the attention that Hegel
attracts right here it's a it's a line change
I think it was radish going to the bench but
it Pagel all the way there's stolen lead pass
eel has a step eel for the gamewinner and he's
stopped by kinan going to gain the Vegas line
barov in W with the coverage on him forcing
him to the corner now feeds it to McDonald
and a shot blocked not sure if it was Hunton
or Patera Nick W first over the board for his
first opportunity in the shootout for the golden
knights this [Applause] season and kinan looked
over his shoulder but had it w loves that move
Jack eel one for four this year his goal was a
game decider here he comes slowly to the net
scores and now Jonathan maraso with a chance
to win it here with a goal and he [Music]
[Applause] does now a stretch pass Matthews
is open he's got martyr Matthews the shot the
rebound soken stopped him twice barzel charging
back the other way got Horvat with them B
Horvat scores G winter New York [Applause]
Highlanders Blocker in position but
it's horat that gets it up in that
top third of the net and sends this
crowd home cheering that's a great
shot orberg eyes the net shots save made
by Arison the rebound score yes [Applause]
sir nice little handoff forsberg does a loop
he's got space and he's attack in the net he's
a shooter he's shooting look at that puck he
knew it games decid of an OT this year Jack eel
the gamewinner in Dallas Flames are three and0
in the overtime eel with a steal here beats it
up ahead stone with a step Jers Mark Stone the
overtime winner his fourth point of the night
and the golden knights in overtime win it 5 to
four 10th of the Season sixth career overtime
goal for Mark Stone his fourth point of the night
for the fans but right now it's just all about
possession and then picking your moment to attack
Crosby got it and he gave it up to Carlson Eric
Carlson coming in shoots multimo to save his
mask is popped off Carlson's got a great set
of wheels and he cuts across and anytime the
defenseman or a forward gives you Suzuki all
the way back to the point the Caufield fires
and elovich got a piece to field on it again
back for Nick Suzuki to the in shooting and the
delovic makes the save aen to your slowski trying
to get away from bar Carlson sovi pass over and
elovich got a piece of that shot for the glove
Daren watch all the way back into the P's end
Brees long ke Riley Smith was there but it was
picked off by Aria y Aria the other way with a
shot and ultimate to Saed pson clears away the
rebound and here comes Nick Suzuki to start it
off Cuts wide left cross the dot into the slot
scores 26 of 80 in the career of Chris leang
the Montreal kid in on mono scores beautiful
just same kind of approach as Suzuki
Coffield Cuts wide on that left side
again into the slot go delovic is coming
down this side I mentioned that they came
down that side quite often during the game
couldn't solve them both suitter came down
the exact same side and he's got two goals
in this game tonight Pros me into the slot
scores goal for such a per long period of time and
now we've seen four in a row on the shootout such
great hands the quick back to front two for two
in the season three for three in his career can
he keep his record perfect off the [Applause] post
Ulan comes down the opposite side though tries to
go back and nothing but iron and gensel with a
chance to win it for Pittsburgh Jake gensel into
the slot hit the post as well it's the caring
of the bills as we go to round four the chance
to put Montreal back in front slav kovski with
speed stopped by NAD delovic 24 for 71 in his
career with 10 game deciding goals Ming in stopped
by MBO let's go to round five Aria one for five in
his career in the shootout he comes in missed
the net Riley Smith Little Speed gets into the
SL stop by Mono 6 for 13 pretty good in these
shootout situations and on delovic missed the
net Eric Carlson slows up get to the
slot hmer the shot and Mulo stands
up to make the save and 18 of 49 in his
career in the shootout he comes in shot
SC yeah 6 for 19 in his career he's
got a score to keep it going Miller
scores I think Marty St Lou was looking down the
bench now who do we go to he goes to Mike Mat the
former Pittsburgh Penguin the defenseman coming
in mat stopped by an elovich Jeff Carter with a
chance now for Pittsburgh Carter in with speed
Carter sto by mtim Mo he'll take a wide route
petta stopped by natovich Al Terry pen with his
first career shootout attempt ptin snapped It
Wide we're going on first ever shootout attempt
here's Evans slows up nalovic stopped him Ram
Zorna with his first career shoot out attempt
out for Pittsburgh zohorna gets in stopped by
m b let's go to round 11 Gallagher with a crowd
on its feet stopped by n elovich Benny henza Cuts
in wide slows down hit stroza stopped by m b one
for two in his career in the shootout Anderson
head fake NAD delovic gets a piece andon Hawkins
after this marathon of a shootout can walk it off
scores happy dads and a shootout winner for
Jon Hawkins and the penguins are winners in
Montreal Luke Hughes turns with space 30 seconds
in overtime he gains the Zone feeds it across Jack
shoots save Swan he threw the rebound off Swan's
back and it didn't go here's jper Brad as Luke
Hughes changes off brat carries Jack Hughes takes
he centers and brat Deni by Swan he here still
rolling and on the puck keeps it in the offensive
end heer turns for goal cuts to the front Swan
got a piece of it Mercer PS it to space jimo nit
in a foot race and he gets there ahead of D Heen
nit turns ruins were changing ja KS to the ground
his shots altered and SW fights it off Myers got
it again he back for Meer he settles Jack Hugh
a one timer sing makes the sa and covered with
234 to go so it is Brad Luke Hughes and Jack
Hughes Luke's going to peel off look like he
took a bit of a stick so he changes Brad puts
the shoulder down he changes Direction Jack
shoots [Applause] Devil's winning [Music]
[Applause] overtime set up by vanich brat
with the entry little change of pace get some time
has both fly winners in overtime this year drops
it back to connect able to move in Fire and the
save by L gr turns this into a three on two rois
downlo a save rebound oetkin he fumbled it now
the Flyers with a the chance they'll move the
butt here's paling ahead for ainson the game on
his stick save made by lindd crowd and the teams
we into the final minute of the three on three
long pass that FES lose oetkin oetkin cutting on
in he shoots and the save made by Arison it's
been pretty consistent there he goes swinging
to the right wing in on lingren Geto straight up
and he scores Oshi 0 for two in the shootout this
season right up the gut there's the big head
fake he scores did Aron ever bite off you talk
about hands for the fers that move to his backand
Forster in the top of the second Forster snap shot
and lingren Dives out with a poke check anytime
you poke check to a player going to his forehand
you run the risk if forcer just holds on to
that so now strong is over for seven in his
career in on goal save harison is not Morgan Frost
Bobby Brink with his first at HL shootout attempt
swings to the right wing Cuts in and dson down and
Tucks it home there's that risk you were talking
about it break takes advantage and I thought he
might have misplayed it here he comes watch him
control it here just about when a little as he
cuts in Anthony man DS and canot score Arison
and the Flyers win the hockey game three shootouts
for Arison there's Lon in behind it but score 1,1
points cing it Mar backit [Applause] scor and
it's 52 and here's Timmons at the line k m fir
scores must score did score 53 tried to kick it
in front KNE Lander shot projected another chance
Matthews fired it's a one go game back behind
it's a d play for Matthews it back it scor are
you watching this the game is tied give up a
five goal lead and now have to find a way to
get something going on over what a valuable point
and now yard throw tried to kick it back to Riley
kep to the line and here's litzky stealing Zack
Linsky break away and off the stop of the rebound
and it's knocked away and now we neander could
have a break and getting back oh KNE ler Steals
and stopped by m linol he's out of gas heading
off here comes Johnny Gad 700 perhaps but shot
it high and now Matthews to the attack two on one
with barter Matthews stops to the rebound thator
behind the net B forth rinsky Johnson lurking on
that left side rinsky Johnson Dan for in Fr shot
scores Ken Johnson his first three-point game it's
the game-winning goal and his second of the night
Columbus six Toronto five yeah for the blue ja
they give up five in the third but hey in overtime
it's Kent Johnson great first period he ends up
ending it but man what a comeback third period
to get us to overtime and it's Johnson who sends
the fans home buzzing now it's the Flames that
are gas long shot got through save lar cadri and
capriso battle capriso wins the fight zukaro fires
oh to the top of the goal ciso tried to center
it went right through the blue Here Comes zuk
Carell to start it for Minnesota and he scores
a zukar stick that's no goal that's what Vadar
is trying to say right now he went for the Poke
he got a p Sharon goic will shoot for Calgary
goal an assist in the game tonight and he scores
Carill capriso next to shoot for Minnesota comes
in with speed and just tried to chip it up over
the glove of badar but missed so the throw in on
badar stop by BL the old scorpion works
that is called second effort period comes
perhaps to your advantage they don't ask how oh
that's beautiful uberto can win it for Calgary
Guston deflex it wide and we move into round
four Baldi who scored the game's first goal
tonight he scores and Minnesota needs a save for a
win cadri against Guston sa Guston a win for the
wild as Yosi stick handles and elicit booze
pass toward O'Reilly and forsberg fortunately
for Nashville gloved down by Philip forsberg
forsberg darts to the slot shoots SC it's over
the PRS win it and again it's Philip forsberg
in overtime for the second time in his many
games 18 seconds into overtime took a little bit
longer here tonight yeah it looked like they're
going to lose possession there but forsberg
drives birs back keep his Puck out his forand
barzel got it to Dobson in front a save from
almart Nelson took that one it's poock out of
the box and here come the Bruins turle coil
over the line the tow drag on barzell he got
the for hat shot away soken the Stop and now
it's the Islanders in transition doson making
it a three on two here's doson cut to the net
save olar rebound save as barzel was crashing
Islanders have to hustle back pook Off the
Bench comes up Horvat got back sokin made
a save well the Islanders with the four on three
and deflection by Horvat very poor four on three
I'm I'm sorry they just they were too stationary
I was this was a good opportunity but look at an
aggressive save by allar and Islanders win
the face off and they head north Corvette to
Dobson can he get there out of the net came
hmark with a poke check and now he's got to
hustle back the only defenseman on the ice
is trailing the play Charlie Coyle working
on Holstrom and Horvat they drop it for Maran he
shoots safe theok and rebound still loose it's
Maran wrestled Away by Holstrom can he spring
Horvat can't get it through good good effort
30 seconds left pass for poo he's got Danton
Hein poono weight shoots off of sokin and over
the top of the net lenus Omar has participated
in a shootout this year B Horvat jams on the
brakes went to the backand and allar stayed with
him got in tight he's over for three this year
barzel never really got the shot away as he went
to the back hand charlot Coyle the shooter for
Boston no goal so far here in the shootout Cole
oh what a move he went glovs side and scory yeah
just get a little fake to his he's had a hot hand
as of late but he's never scored in a shootout
he's 0 for three in his career holmstrom
needs to score oh and he did with style
ala fron neelon and goes up and high like
right up and again see where uh allar ends
up soon as he pulls it he drops down and
you can go up with it one they needed a
goal they got it now they need a save from
sokin against David posto poono just rips
it home scores and the Bruins have won it well
that was that was too easy look POS he just got
it there and he's he's just he's just going
to whip it right by Hugh circles away from
gdo still with the puck gives to Garland
tries to cut through the slot and Guston
covers COV to the bench as Johansson drives
in Johansson to zuk Carell a shot saved by the
Smith zuk Carell in against the Smith and he
scores oh play look at it
it's where that goal stick
turns Miller swings wide stain on the backand
and gustaffson knocks it down with a glove
caprico can win it for Minnesota capriso in and
he fires the Vander over the top of the [Music]
goal and a see by Guston and it's
another shootout win for the wild
drops it off tro takes it back out
played two minutes fans getting on
the rangers they have the puck having
shot here down low tro scores rers
win Vincent tro paner and he just deflect it
in no chance for San troch scores them both he'll
drop it off for Thomas trying to find some room
and some speed to the Speedster CYO he darts up
the middle in on goal CYO sa rebound they score
Jordan Spence Bill den no now he'll Tee It Up no
he won't hammered by Kelly up denied by dord in
front broken up by gour to the outside 12 seconds
on the power play Arthur CV F to no CV swallowed
up by Joey dord well joy dord right here makes a
big save sliding over for the one time opportunity
can see him run the shootout yor strand moving
in weaving his way towards the front of the net
and he Geeks and a globe save by talit well this
time Tomas Tatar what a moment here stopped by can
talit Pierre Luke dubba in the two- hole for Todd
mclen stopped by 35 the Kraken have one shootout
The Cider this season Kyler Yamamoto has it make
it to a Spokan Special by Kyler [Music] [Applause]
Yamamoto he swoops in he scores Adrien Kee will
extend the shootout an Kopitar the
future Hall of Famer it's in his
hands stopped goal line stand close
as it gets the overhead is going to
be a perfect view here off the toe
Kevin [Applause] fiala takes a look
at dord stopped dord holds his ground
again Jared mccan round number six
shut down Quinton Byfield having a great
season his opportunity off the goal post
how about a late birthday gift for
the pepper pot Here Comes gourd he
scores earlier everyone slowing things down he
kept going he changed it up he changed
the whole look the game on the line he
scores we go deeper cool as can
be and you can see how many times
C have stick out watch him change
once twice all the way across his
moves in scores what a move by the
reigning Rookie of the Year stick
magnet he had the big the big fake tber bit
Lewis needs it Trevor Lewis the veteran a
right shot in on goal DS and he scores was
ready watch this oh yeah he only waved one
move but that move because the go when you
make the Poke and Miss ninth round stick save
cam talut real good release he has a chance to
win it one of two in his career in a shootout
grundstrom to win it in shoots scores Carl
grundstrom in the ninth round of the shootout
wins the game for the Kings now NES NIS going
wide cutting Around the Net R chance and keer
gets across and now the Caps scaring with it
it's sanine he's got stro stro made on Coach
jov it's knocked away well B lead off and here
comes Sebastian AO he's one for one this year
AO in on keer Waits back in forehand and keer
seals off the bottom of the net here he comes
at the snails pace now just push it forward
now he'll get to it he's one for three on the
year and it he'll score Jarvis up for Carolina he
has to to score Jarvis on his forehand snapped it
high Washington wins for Suzuki he'll switch Sid
Suzuki to Coffield waiting back to Baron shooting
scores watch here as Baron ends up getting that
puck that return feed right between the some
pressure legs for the Kraken Larsson hands to AC
cross bers and then makes his way to the bench
here's bers darting left side a shot off the
outside of the [Applause] post right off that
far post by Matt there was a little hitch in the
delivery there that I think mess things up done is
the Kraken again in bers curling behind the that
wrap around Wedgewood got over to make the save
and then he circles the wagons Wedgewood down and
oh man great SA almost stars have never trailed in
the contest led by as many as two a couple of
occasions here's Harley back to Du shaine two
goals in the game he waits F in front score he
put it right on the tape of Thomas Harley once
duain got it Matt just stood there and he was
wide open now he's got it the side of the net
pivots back esper brat hands off to Hughes he's
bumped by pal got through him Center it back out
NE shot save Aron fires with a chance they move
it ahead here's faraby farab moving up the ice
has help coming he waits he waits he fires save
and a check boxes it around and covers up the
ice great job by Jack Hughes to escape the hit
from paling knocks it back Marino steps under
some pressure and makes a smart play to he as
Jack Hugh pops out again there you go cier go
shoots Aron makes another save and now C's got
a chance to go Jack Hughes racing back he slows
cier who was running low on gas at the end of
a shift to the front connect brings it off the
post luk Hughes across a steal by tippet the
game on his stick he [Applause] scores otot
Tipp it wins it for Philadelphia 32 is your final
he's a pick boock artist and then he goes in and
beats that a jack love side Jack Hughes thinks
he's got tippet beat but tippet was one step
ahead and look at that [Applause] snipe plenty
of chances in this overtime session both ways
he finds makoy to pack fire saved by flurry and
why not one more postac shot on Mark Andre flurry
tonight marad who had the game tying goal drags
to the slot poke checked Away by Faber Baldi
strips him with the puck Baldi on the Breakaway
in for the win save by elar he thought he had an
opportunity to take Baldi oneon-one but Baldi
wins that battle back to Cole Coyle into the
Minnesota Zone up to the slot blurry looking
behind him but the puck is safe now to bruss
working against Faber for the second game in a
row is over four miles of skating tonight wild
have numbers the other way ericon to capriso
he scores second of the night capriso wins it
for the wild in overtime first time in nearly two
periods this building has been quiet Ericson want
another one to start this power play Dylan stro
will advance play it cross eyes Carlton wi and
fires fought off rebound batted out of the air
by Wilson spot stro stro do a better shooting
angle waights feeds with oetkin up top snap
shot of the way score Dylan stro wins it for
Washington
point streak with a tieing goal now marchenko
can he be the hero again tonight marchenko down
the left wing a wrist shot and lingren the save
who has the first of the two goals but it's Tom
Wilson a left wing pass and a breakaway moving
in denied Elvis M leans coming out makes the
save oh he's got to be careful he's going to get
an interference heed up getting under the skin of
Elvis M le as Elvis you can see Wilson gets thrown
in there Wilson sets the table again Carlson
Around the Horn stro looking for the win oetkin
fires broken up in front stro on the feed Carlson
waits to pull the trigger so to D stro angling in
with options kicked out Wilson rolling for Carlson
John Carlson to Dylan stro stro through the
seam oetkin fired score the great weight is over
Hallelujah for o the fans booing here we're loving
life oh vkin the gwg in overtime he's done it his
whole career and he beats M Lincoln he's got Lan
wide open in foot deflected wide by Rael hains
got it again the shot save the check out Malin
handle the pass takes it back 30 seconds left in
OT m going to open up fire save made Crosby denied
on the rebound Crosby back to Malin Carlson what
Tim blocked rebound it's loose and the Pence can't
put it in 20 seconds to go here's Carlson back to
Malin shot is blocked one timer off the crossb
from Crosby are you kidding me Sydney Crosby
43 of 110 in his career in the shootout here
Here Comes Crosby [Applause] score this came
in measuring quick hands and then it's gone see
uh for Carolina save from the delovic puts the
Penguins in the driver's seat here's fetch nikov
twisting and turning stop made by NAD delovic
with the check Ops stopped him terrain to keep it
alive for Carolina MC doovic says
no and the Penguins win it in the
shootout already the regulation Hero trying
to be the overtime hero maybe Robertson let's
Circle his shot saved by Demco people don't
fully understand the idea of patience the
the patience part usually because hin
in for D poked away and now a two on0
for Vancouver Pon with Joshua Pon to Joshua
Pon shot save Wedgewood sealed and low it's
a two onone from three zones away one last
Rush Harley ahead sprung Shane he's in he
scores his sixth game-winning goal of the Season
that leads the NHL it's another electric overtime
for 55 already in the back pocket of Marco
Rossi as he enters the Zone leaves to Faber
Faber fires just wide long rebound man hustling
after it two onone with Coffield man fires save
Guston rebound Caufield knocked it on net
and Guston snatches it with a glove Faber
capriso in with speed capriso swings wide tried
to Center bounces to Johansson Johansson centers
capro
unbelievable the thrill does it again and the
Wild win it four three and overtime that's his
eighth in the Minnesota Wild uniform watch how
he just slick slickly moves to the backside what
a pass by Joe Hansson and the Russian makes
no mistake here's zanim zanim open is concy
saved by Rymer concy with it again slot shot oh
just missed debret still with it coner couldn't
set up Goss to bring It Wide Open there
it is Big save by Carter har gos be with
to Brink C Bear to the middle drops to Brink
St by heart they come couldn't get P hand on
shz good Save Right pad by Hart Comer rasm
and Gus be Flyers control the drop for rist
the line in save oh and that hit Rymer in the
head uhoh what's the referee doing well the
mask came off so they blow the whistle that I
get I thought he was going for more than that
go bit a former flyer to Center on the wing for
Larin with C there it is oh what a stop oh what
a save by Carter Hart he saved this one for
Philadelphia second shooter Raymond wide left
scores he didn't cool around here one for one this
season denied there watch the left the right
pad blocker yeah I think he gets a little bit
of his block first shoot at attempt as a red wing
two and one in the game Patrick Kane scar Brad
Wings win it 7-6 patri Kane what a [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] wow Wilson stacked up with
headman Washington has a two-on-one developing
on a stretch Dylan stroes in stro fires missed
it short side Connor turns 23 in the first month
of 24 off and running here two-on one settles cin
drag fire balesi the save looking to create Chris
Crossing there centering pass was a beauty Hegel
on the backand trapped there stuff attempt in a
diving lingren made the save who Nets off against
vasileski in round one slows the pace inching
closer fires it [Applause] scores hearing it
from the boob Birds rooting against him here in
Washington Santos Glides in forehand carry and
strome looking to give Washington a commanding
lead in the shootout stro holds fire is denied
there by vasileski it'll be Braden point in
the bottom of the second straight up the gut
Point fires and scores and he got lucky there
he lost the pock on him and then he just shot
it watch him bounce the puck off his stick right
there oetkin in the top of the third snaking his
way in on vasileski off that head fake pad saves
Nikita kucherov shooting for the win for Tampa
Bay kucherov dangles in fires Linden gets the
glove on that headman again with a chance to
win it gathers the puck moves in and [Music]
scores Victor Hond Merry Christmas Lightning
win it off the post on a beautiful shot whoops
that part wasn't planned but watch him pull it
back wait wait and throws it up top makes
it back of the line watched by Malin Malin
all over ch he hold his all he does can he
play the Pue he does pon tight scoop let's
go this could have went either way right here B
and chipper battle and Rael besides he's going
to lean on the one side thinking this could
be a breakaway for me and instead it turns
around feeds Panera he shoots it block with the
stick by Clifton here's Panera he's got crder oh
that was blocked by a sliding Samuelson lead
pass that was tipped away Rangers blocked it
take it back to to Middle St Middle St to the net
save sh Sten he saved the game right there Miller
moves it middle stat comes out Chek trying to get
back Middle St save rebound tck save just stking
with two more Beauties Ryder with Saad that's
deflected across a stick went down that would
belong to Quinn here's saned to the net Around
the Net pass score score the rers winning it over
time and then down the other end after he
had made a couple more zabana Jad is going
to be so patient hold hold it hold it hold it
throw it in front Bean Dro past bom's got it
tries to feather it back in front it comes to
Johns on it and Teo Myers up to the races game
on Meers stick he shoots he [Applause] scores
Teo Meer wins it as the Devils come all the
way [Music] back schz for Keller Keller wide
turn for Kess ring Kess ring shoots and a stop
gorgia K likes to pull this back in the neutral
zone and just come right at you with speed here
he comes and a stop by Cara mil iel carone's
got some room brings it in carcone right to
the net oh and he can't get it pass Manson made
the play and balamaki with a point blanker oh
my what a move by carcone Zer behind the net
out High Jersy and now zooker just give it to
thy and end this suer with a shot 32 seconds
remaining Stripped Away Coyote's get it in
over the line suer Jersy to suer he's stopped
byor everybody in it's in coyotes [Applause]
win [Applause]
unbelievable connection not there now boiler
it's a three onone for the Hawks to Win It
boiler Kinski Kinski bili and he couldn't get
a shot away now morisy in alone on moric morisy
stopped by bazic Neer Rider backhand save
bazic oh my goodness what a play by Lucas
reel to create that three onone and boila I
don't think he was expecting it to come back
to him Bard now Main Street he [Music] scores
it's [Applause] over Conor Bard's second goal
of the game he bookends this one a first period
ice breaker and an overtime game winner to Bret
oh and a screen going to wman with two goals
tonight leaves for de Brink gives to Raymond
it he does he scores Locus Raymond Red Wings
with it 5 to four how do you like that so the
tie work does the at a boy and it just throws
the goal tender enough time for that buck to
find the back of the net and he gets his second
in 11 or 12 games approaching the one minute
Mark now vanelli who tied it vanelli spit down the
right side vanelli with a shot oh a glove save by
Sams Matthews back in with Marner and MCC
Matthews Miss short side it's a little odd
to it I didn't realize it was off the bar
we uh we wondered if he was hurt there it BR
again G [Applause] [Music] [Applause] scores
here's from the face off good job by Dan for
and now good dr's all Al you can see samsonov
locks himself up on that PL hand off for hiny
Miro hiny for duchaine right wing side duain
to the slot his shot in a glove save by morz
smart changing the the Hawks and a weave
to the forand and the slot with 16 left in
overtime hinin leaves it for hints hint into
the Zone over for hinan now Robertson hits he
scores hatrick overtime game over Stars win it
5 to four to back door wide openen yawning cage
tappins that's backto back season with
Gordon Schultz yorran will dangle the
Maestro shot denied by Hart there was
some room on that short Side High some
tired guys out there right now for Philly
see if the Kraken can capitalize Bor strand
downstairs they score hey hey what do
you say Justin shs and the Kraken win in
overtime Justin Schultz see gourd gives it to bork
Strand and he gives it to Schultz and then the
redirect but let's not forget again Columbus
still get the puck and we'll see if they change
or they're going to go for it here is Danforth in
behind everybody dan for puts it high Skinner's
going to pull it back and they want Thompson
involved with this here's Thompson nice move back
out off the out side of the post in behind the
goal power for skers for Skinner Skinner overtime
winner and this is Dage Thompson he makes a
nice move just getting his Puck to the net and
then he wins the battle down low and by winning
that battle he's able to find working laterally
there's forsberg pressure comes from oetkin
forsberg gets through on his way to the goal
pad stopped Shephard rebound dors step still there
and no goal little mind game here everybody quiet
ketov is stopped by escaro a clutch save by the
rookie clutch save and I love it K net off nist
he will also take his time dried all the way wide
now works his way in he scores round one to the
Predators now it is Russian versus Russian round
two oetkin the great a against young ascara Ed is
ascar coming up with another save he has stopped
the two Russian Legends O'Reilly can end it here
O'Reilly approaches he scor the Predators win
it the first career win for yaroslav letarov he
stops KET off and oetkin in the shootout Kee
in front kopar in in two deep the rer round
denied
things have an advantage here with the Personnel
they have on the ice du in with fiala dub to fiala
hit a leg almost went in hit an Oiler four of nine
in his career as he just saw a left shot more in
shoots and scores in on an angle McDavid in on
gold Dees and scores to the season for the veteran
campe winds his way in on goal shoots and [Music]
scores in on talin daks and scores let's see how
slow he goes here for shooting room head up turn
now slow it down just slow slow slow and look by
the time the shot there's a little bit of a deep
there Leon dry Sidle a left shot in save is made
the veteran Andre Kopitar his third attempt
this season in shoots glove save Derek Bryan
W for for his career look at that SK
he's coming in and he scores and there
you have it the Edmonton Oilers victorious
in game number 600 of Conor mcdavid's career